[Musique]
mais ceux d'un premier serait de voir
qu'on tourne dans ce nouveau décor je
suis ravi alors quelles vont être les
trois histoires du jour les mécaniques
savantes elle est satisfaisante mais
attendait aujourd'hui c'est la première
fois qu'on va faire une histoire bonus
qui s'intitule l'histoire hashtag had de
julie mais attendez attendez on a écrit
un truc et où j'aime bien bonjour il me
faut de licence bonjour moi ses marques
ok moi c'est jennifer vous voulez un
conseil
non juste des licences vous n'êtes pas
en sécurité
oh purée de pommes de terre je suis dans
un thread horreur c'est ça non pas du
tout je parlais de votre ordinateur
qu'est-ce qu'il a mon ordinateur il a
besoin de nos vpn
je savais que j'aurais dû aller à
l'autre pointe l'essai et son risque
vous elle garantit 30 jours vous
rembourser mais je sais même pas ce que
c'est c'est un réseau privé virtuel qui
vous permet plein davantage comme par
exemple regarder le catalogue netflix
des autres pays
est-ce qu'il me permet de faire le plein
d'essence nos ne vous pouvez surfer en
toute sécurité sur les réseaux wifi
publics super et bien merci du conseil
maintenance grâce à l'ong euros
d'inscription et mot code promo squeeze
vous obtiendrez un abonnement de deux
ans et un mois supplémentaire avec une
super réduction maman je vais être en
retard à l'école attend timothée le
monsieur nous fait un placement de
produit
ça ne m'intéresse pas timothée est ce
que tu aimes damon slayer de fou avec
nos bpn
tu peux te connecter au japon et voir
des mangas préférés sur le catalogue
netflix japonais ok je veux bien le code
promo finalement non
il est valable pour tout le monde sauf
pour toi je vais mettre le feu à votre
station rendez-vous en descriptions pas
mal pas mal merci je lis on passe à la
première de risque et attendez avant
qu'on commence j'ai vu qu'il ya plein de
gens qui regardent laisserait d'horreur
en couple qu'ils prennent ça comme un
prétexte pour se coller à leurs amoureux
ou amoureuse collet vous prenez-vous
dans les bras que de la bourse ça me
fait plaisir aux carences tout de suite
avec la première histoire qui est celle
de alix l'histoire se passe quand alix
avait encore 14 ans faut savoir calix
est l'aîné de la famille et donc comme
tous les aînés parmi vous vous le savez
on vous a déjà demandé de garder le
petit frère ou la petite soeur et bat
l'époque alix on lui a demandé de garder
ses trois petits cousins ça fait
beaucoup de responsabilités pour un ado
de 14 ans sa tante et son oncle lui
demande de faire la baby sitter parce
qu'ils se rendaient à un mariage
ils vont donc passer la journée à plus
d'une heure de la maison est rentré très
tard
mais alors où est donc cette maison elle
est en pennsylvanie c'est une grande
maison familiale qui est sur un flanc de
montagne au milieu de rien vraiment de
rien et la route principale la plus
proche donc une route assez fréquemment
empruntée est à un kilomètre de la
maison
bon en gros vous l'aurez compris on
parle vraiment d'une maison bien isolée
tu te retrouves pas proche de cette
maison accidentellement ce bar possible
bref avant de partir sa tante et son
oncle lui laisse de l'argent pour
commander des pizzas et il laisse aussi
leur numéro de téléphone portable à côté
de la ligne fixe du téléphone de la
maison parce que oui ça se passe au
début des années 2000 donc alix n'a
absolument pas de portable et elle dit
que même s'il en avait eu un vu
l'endroit où est la maison elle aurait
probablement pas eu de réseau du tout
bref il est 20h le bébé de 1 an d'or
l'enfant de 4 ans et posé devant la
télévision dans le salon et à l'état
alix est en train de jouer à guitar hero
avec l'enfant de 8 ans alix dans la
pièce où elle est en regardant à gauche
elle a une vue sur le salon salon dans
lequel donc à l'enfant de 4 ans qui est
posé devant la télé et en regardant à
droite y est une fenêtre qui mène sur
une allée quand on prends à droite c'est
aller en arrivant devant la maison il ya
un abri à voiture qui est prévu pour
pouvoir se garer là mais cette année
elle continue aussi un peu plus loin et
elle fait le tour elle passe aussi
derrière la maison
sauf que personne ne vient jamais en
voiture derrière la maison puisque ça
sert à rien étant donné qu'ils utilisent
l'espace arrière comme cour de récré
pour les enfants donc à plein de jouets
qui traînent ya souvent des enfants
dehors qui joue bref que ce soit l'oncle
et la tante de alix où tous leurs amis
personne n'a même jamais sa voiture
derrière la maison dans cette cour de
récré il ya évidemment un garage mais
qui en réalité ne stocke aucune voiture
c'est plus l'atelier de l'oncle d'alix
dans lequel il bricole et dans ce garage
et une porte qui mène à l'intérieur de
la maison
maintenant vous avez tout ça en tête
petite avance rapide il est plus 20
heures il est 22 heures il fait nuit
noire
alix et toujours avec son cousin en
train de jouer à guitar hero et sur sa
droite et lumière
à travers la fenêtre qui attire son oeil
à l'excellent pense dans un premier
temps que sa tante et son oncle sont de
retour plutôt prévu sauf quand on entend
la tête elle s'aperçoit que c'est pas du
tout les phares du monospace de sa tante
mais que c'est les phares d'un énorme
truc
elle a donc jamais vu ce véhicule et en
plus de ça elle comprend que le véhicule
n'est pas en train de se garer sous
l'abri à voiture qui est devant la
maison mais il est en train de continuer
son chemin dans l'allée pour arriver
derrière la maison
elle en déduit donc immédiatement que
cette personne n'est pas une habituée
des lieux et qu'elle est jamais venu ici
alix descend dans le salon et elle prend
immédiatement le téléphone de la ligne
fixe pour appeler le 911 la police elle
a même pas le temps d'avoir un opérateur
au téléphone qu'elle entend la porte du
garage être secoué violemment
elle comprend donc vite la situation un
inconnu essaie d'entrer dans la maison
dans laquelle il ya juste elle et ses
trois petits cousins dont elle doit
s'occuper et la soulagement pour alix
elle a enfin un opérateur au téléphone
opérateurs qui va rapidement lui
expliquer qu'il y aura personne sur
place avant trente minutes puisque la
maison est complètement perdue au milieu
d'une montagne
l'opératrice lui dit qu'elle va la
garder en ligne pendant ce temps et elle
lui demande aussi le numéro de sa tante
pour la prévenir pour qu'elles rendent
plutôt prévu du mariage alix se retourne
pour prendre le papier que sa tante lui
a laissé papier sur lequel il ya le
numéro de téléphone de sa tante et en se
retournant elle voit à travers une
fenêtre un homme et cet homme il est en
train de lui sourire
comme si la situation la muse et alix
elle est complètement terrorisée et
avant même qu'elle puisse dire quoi que
ce soit à l'opérateur ya jake son petit
cousin qui regardent inconnu dehors en
disant monsieur jim jay qui dit ça d'une
voix confuses comme s'il était ni
content ni soulagé de voir monsieur jim
et en voyant la réaction bizarre de jake
alix elle regarde inconnue et elle lui
explique qu'elle est au téléphone avec
la police et qui sont déjà en route
l'inconnue regard d'alex droit dans les
yeux il fronce les sourcils et il prend
quelques secondes à lui comme pour
réfléchir de ce qu'il allait faire
et finalement il recule et il disparaît
dans l'obscurité
quelques minutes plus tard alix voit les
phares du camion sera lui mais est elle
le voit partir et descendre l'allée en
rentrant l'oncle d'alix était
apparemment furieux contre ce monsieur
jim elles attendent alix elle semblait
très en colère contre l'oncle d'alix de
pas avoir déjà réglé ses histoires avec
monsieur jim comme elle le lui avait
déjà demandé en fait alix elle ne savait
pas à l'époque et l'a compris beaucoup
plus tard mais son nom qu'il avait un
problème d'addiction aux drogues
et ce monsieur jim c'était le dealer de
son nom et ce dealer il avait
apparemment pas été payés depuis un
petit moment et il était donc venu pour
[ __ ] le bordel et faire pression sur
monsieur jim pour qui le paye sauf que
c'est pas sûr monsieur jim qu'il est
tombé c'est sûr alix 14 ans qui s'occupe
de tout
enfant seul dans une maison isolée et en
plus ce dealer apparemment prenez du
plaisir à terroriser une enfant c'est
terrible je n'aurais jamais assumé bilan
de cette histoire avant de faire du
baby-sitting et gardez vos petits
cousins
soyez au courant des histoires de vos
oncles et tantes 1 voilà un mec qui
vient toquer pour embrouiller le l'oncle
soul qui tombe sur toile c'est vite
arrivé
il est maintenant temps de passer à la
deuxième histoire celle de coralie qui
n'a rien à voir c'est une histoire qui
s'est passée en 2017 quand coralie avait
19 ans à l'époque elle vit dans l'une
des nombreuses banlieues résidentielles
de sa ville elle explique qu'à l'époque
elle est un peu naïve elle considère
qu'elle vit dans un endroit qui est
hyper safe qu'il ait jamais rien arriver
de mal dans sa résidence etc
et du coup elle fait des trucs qu'elle
se permettrait plus de faire aujourd'hui
alors c'est pas du tout les trucs de ouf
enfin c'est juste sortir ou rentrer tard
quand il fait nuit seul mais cette année
là il ya trois trucs de blizzard qui lui
sont arrivés et le dernier de ses trois
trucs a radicalement changé son
comportement
un soir coralie elle saura cet art des
cours il est aux alentours de 22 heures
elle prend le bus elle descend à l'arrêt
de bus les plus proches de chez elle
elle a étudié toute la journée il est
tard elle est clairement fatigué et pas
très attentive à ce qui se passe autour
d'elle mais en se dirigeant vers son
immeuble elle remarque quand même
qu'elle vient de passer à côté d'une
personne accroupis dans le noir
évidemment ça l'a un peu fait bad et
elle n'a pas pris le temps de s'arrêter
elle s'en fout chacun sa merde
et puis un peu plus tard quand il
s'apprête à se coucher elle entend des
bruits de bagarre qui viennent de
l'extérieur coraline elle habite au
deuxième étage donc elle se dirige vers
sa fenêtre pour l'ouvrir et demander si
tout va bien et le temps qu'elle louvre
il n'y a plus un bruit à l'extérieur bon
chorale elle va clairement pas décent d
aller dans la rue voir si tout va bien
elle envoie juste un message aux
propriétaires de son appart pour le
prévenir de ce qui vient de se passer de
ce qu'elle est entendue
et puis elle va se coucher et là il va
rien se passer pendant plusieurs
semaines mais un soir il est tard
coralie part de chez elle pour aller
faire des courses avant que sa ferme et
sur le retour du chemin des courses en
marchant vers son immeuble elle voit de
nouveau quelqu'un a croupi cette fois
près d'un buisson près de son bâtiment
est cette fois sept personnes accroupies
elle efface à coralie est elle la
regarde
coralie face à sale sais pas trop quoi
faire et elle fait naïvement 1 cl demain
et la personne qui la regarde elle ne
réagit absolument pas à ce sig demain
coralie se dirige vers son bâtiment elle
passe à quelques mètres de cette
personne et puis elle arrive à rentrer
chez elle dans son appartement et tout
va bien
en fait dans ce genre de situation c'est
très compliqué de réaliser qu'il se
passe un truc anormal est alarmant et
très souvent dans le méga déni que tu
continues à faire ta vie tu fais comme
si ça n'existait pas et hélas c'est
exactement ce que coralie elle fait elle
envoie donc une nouvelle fois un message
à son propriétaire pour lui dirai au
fait j'ai revu la personne que je vis à
quatre semaines qui était immobile
accroupi et son propriétaire lui répond
qu'il a reçu plusieurs messages d'autres
locataires qui lui ont signalé la même
chose à partir de là trois mois passe
sans qu'elle retrouve sur cette personne
jusqu'au 3
un incident qui cette fois n'a pas
laissé coralliens différentes ce soir-là
coralie elle est chez elle avec son mec
et ils viennent de s'embrouiller son mec
et soul et il décide de rentrer chez lui
et coralie se voit mal le laisser
rentrer chez lui seul comme il n'habite
pas très loin il décide de le
raccompagner chez lui à pied et sur le
chemin du retour quand chorale y est
seule elle tombe une nouvelle fois sur
cette fameuse silhouette qui est cette
fois non pas accroupi dans un buisson
mais debout sous le réverbère au milieu
de la route
sauf que l'accord allait pour entrer
chez elle doit vraiment passé à côté de
lui et elle ne sent pas du tout du coup
elle s'est caché derrière un arbre
en attendant qu'ils dégagent hélas les
minutes passent mais le mec ne bougent
pas ils restent là debout au milieu de
la route à regarder au loin elle
n'arrive pas du tout à comprendre ce
qu'il veut parce que c'est
incompréhensible quelqu'un qui est
immobile au milieu d'une route sous un
lampadaire fin qu'est ce qu'il fout quoi
sauf qu'après trente minutes attend
derrière l'arbre coralie l envie de
rentrer chez elles et donc elle se dit
bon franchement j'abuse franchement
j'abuse le mec il est juste là debout à
regarder des trucs que je m'en fous
qu'est ce que je raconte sue par ado
elle se relève donc qu'elle se met à
marcher vers son bâtiment en essayant
d'avoir l'air le plus neutre possible
elle s'approche doucement de cette
inconnue et puis elle arrive à son
niveau et en passant à côté de lui
elle a un vieux feeling elle se dit je
le sens pas je vais courir maintenant et
au moment où elle se met à courir le mec
derrière le crie dessus coralliennes
cours de toutes ses forces sur le
gravier et dans sa course elle a
l'impression d'entendre du gravier
bouger derrière elle comme si le mec le
cours et après elle réussit à rentrer
dans le bâtiment a fermé la porte et
elle trace jusqu'au deuxième étage
jusqu'à chez elle et elle appelle
immédiatement la police est d'ailleurs
n'appelle pas que la police
elle appelle aussi ses voisins dont alan
numéro des membres de sa famille son mec
bref tout le monde est au courant de ce
qui lui arrivait les jours passent
coralie ne sort plus quand il fait nuit
elle est quand même bien choqués de ce
qui vient de lui arriver et c'est normal
c'est choquant et puis elle a des news
de son propriétaire
il a pu se procurer les images de
vidéosurveillance de l'incident survenu
quelques jours avant et malheureusement
coralie n'a rien inventé sur les images
de la vidéosurveillance
on voit bel et bien un inconnu
courir après coralie et se jeter dans un
buisson juste après coralie et réussi à
rentrer dans son bâtiment et à partir de
là plus aucune nouvelle coralie n'a plus
jamais revu cette personne n a jamais su
ce qu'ils foutent est accroupi dans des
buissons ou debout au milieu de la route
dans son quartier tard le soir
elle sait juste que aucun voisin ne l'a
jamais revu depuis cet incident et
qu'elle désormais elle évite de sortir
ou de rentrer quand il fait du camp
qu'il en soit si vous voyez des gens
rodez bizarre dans votre quartier est
immobile est chelou faites vous
confiance ce n'est pas normal
voilà prenez soin de vous la sécurité
avant tout ça me fait bander
maintenant je vous racontais l'histoire
de josh c'est une histoire qui s'est
passé il ya quelques années josh à cette
époque est chez lui avec son chien et
avec le recul à chaque fois qu'il
repense à cette histoire il se dit
qu'est ce que c'était que ce bordel ce
jour-là il est 23 heures il fait nuit
dehors et josh hill et posé devant sa
télé avec son chien à côté de lui le
genre de soirée qu'on adore et l'entente
une voiture devant sa maison couper son
auteur georges prend pas la peine de se
lever et se dit que c'est probablement
son voisin d'en face qui vient de
rentrer du travail mais son chien n'est
pas du même avis et lui décident d'aller
voir par la fenêtre qui vient de couper
le moteur de sa voiture en allant voir
par la fenêtre le chien abîme un peu le
store de josh ce qui force josh à se
lever et à aller auprès de sa fenêtre
pour le remettre en place et en arrivant
près de sa fenêtre josh hill voit qu'à
l'extérieur il ya bel et bien une
voiture qui est garé devant chez lui il
distingue pas trop de détails mais voit
que le conducteur ait encore assis dans
la voiture et ça m'interpelle pas plus
que ce à quoi les gens font leur vie
c'est un quartier ya du passage bon il
s'en fout et sert un petit verdot il
retourne se poser devant la télé à
regarder sa série et la 15 minutes après
qu'il ait réparé son store et vu la
voiture garée devant chez lui josh il
entend quelqu'un peut tapoter à sa porte
il précise il entend pas toc et il
entend tapoter ces genres très léger
josh met en pause sa série pour mieux
entendre et son chien lui va s'asseoir
devant la porte d'entrée
et c'est là qu'il entend apporter cette
fois ne pas la porte d'entrée les à sa
fenêtre
josh se lève il va écarter de lamelles
de son store pour voir qui est à la
fenêtre et avant même qu'ils aient le
temps de distinguer le visage de cette
personne elle retourne tapoter à la
porte d'entrée
et cette fois le tapotement il va durer
plusieurs dizaines de secondes et comme
il n'attend pas de visite et que c'est
pas du tout genre de sa famille ou de
ses amis dû faire des surprises et
débarquer chez lui et comprend que là il
se passe un truc bizarre
du coup il fait un move très malin il
ouvrit la fenêtre ni sa porte d'entrée
et monta les tâches de chez lui et il
ouvre la fenêtre à l'étagé
il voit donc l'inconnu qui en bas de
chez lui et il le dit bonjour
vous voulez quoi et ce mec lui réponds
que c'est le livreur de la pizza qui
lasse à margarita et qu'ils lui doivent
un dollar hélas josh hill ce sens mes
gars qu'on est immédiatement il se dit
[ __ ] mais en fait le mec a tapoté
parce qu'il est 23 heures et il voulait
pas faire trop de bruit pour les voisins
c'est tout par contre josh n'a pas
commandé des pizzas et il le fait savoir
il dit aux gars mais je suis désolé mais
j'ai pas comment des pizzas mais le
livreur tchèque son téléphone et lui dit
écoute mais que je suis bel et bien la
bonne adresse je fais juste mon taf
décent et ouvre la porte
sauf que même si il fait sombre sur le
palier de josh georges voit bien que
dans ses mains
il a rien le mec est là les changes va
durer un petit moment et josh n'en
démord pas il lui dit frérot je n'ai pas
commandés pizza soit à la mauvaise
adresse soit hutin vente une vie tu n'es
pas livreur de pizza hélas malgré tout
ce que josh va pouvoir dire à ce mec
ce mec va pas arrêter de lui dire à
l'aider sans mouvement la porte donne
moi ce que tu le dois et prends ta pizza
s'te plaît à tel point qu'au bout d'un
moment le voisin de josh celui qui
habite en face de l'autre côté la
voiture garée sort de chez lui pour voir
ce qui se passe parce qu'il entend du
bruit depuis plusieurs minutes
et en voyant ça le livreur de pizza
fantôme immédiatement retourne à la
voiture là démarre et se casse et c'est
la fin de l'histoire
encore à ce jour josh il comprend pas ce
qui s'est passé ce soir là que voulait
ce gars est ce que le gars y était
peut-être dans une phase où il était
complètement déséquilibré il pensait
vraiment qui venait livrer une pizza
est-ce qu'il avait une stratégie mal
cette derrière il fait genre c'est un
livreur est en fait il rentre chez toi
il fait chier pas quoi josh n'a aucune
réponse voilà il raconte juste en mode
les gars il m'est arrivé ça c'est quoi
cette merde
merci au revoir est ce que c'est bon
pour vous ce genre de rencontres ce
genre d'interaction sociale avec
d'autres humains est ce qu elles vous
plaisent ces interactions portez vous
bien j'espère que ça vous a plu j'espère
que vous étiez bien dans l'ambiance avec
le décor je suis très content je trouve
ça mais encore plus dans l'ambiance
et puis a très vite gros bisous et swizz
autres
[Musique]